and it's the heart of it that is so hard  to talk about I mean I skim the ideas  off the depth of a sea of heart whose  boundaries cannot be taken because  that's my style but the unsaid part the  dizziness of the things unsaid remember  the poem by Trumbull Stickney I lean  over your meanings edge and I feel the  dizziness of the things you have not  said and the dizziness of the things  unsaid for us fans of dizziness is  ecstasy the vertigo weren't we first  spun in the schoolyard wasn't that your  first altered state of consciousness to  be spun and spun until you fall down and  watch the world move around its the  dizziness of the things unsaid that's a  real problem for me I'm a sailor but  it's worth invoking it if only to let it  resonate in the silence  you